all right
fluka yes where where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
i grew up in long beach and tell me
about your family you had both your
parents i know i
grew up with my mother uh and a
stepfather
uh he's actually been in our our lives
for since i
i was a little girl um but before that
it was just like random ass guys right
you know
typical [ __ ] your parents do leave you
at home type [ __ ] or whatever
and how was your childhood um it was
pretty [ __ ] up um
for whatever reason i was always being
attacked
by my mother we never really got along
it was always just you know
whatever happened in the household with
another sibling it was always my fault
and
you know it was just it was kind of
[ __ ] up
um and then uh that's when she got my
stepdad
and you know they used to get well they
used to party every weekend you know
leave friday whatever party all night
till sunday come home
sleep all day on sunday um
and uh they had you know at that time i
probably was like in
like fourth grade maybe third fourth
grade uh
and they had a friend that used to come
over with them and uh
you know he pretty much just tried to
take advantage of me
um you know i had my clothes down trying
to like offer me money to like
how are you i was young i was like six
or seven somewhere around there like
between those ages i'm not really sure
to remember um
but i remember i was scared and i told
my cousin and she said you know you got
to tell your mom and i was like
you know it's not it wasn't one of those
things where you know you
you can go tell your mom like look this
is happening to me you know like
and so i kept it to myself until it
happened to my cousin and then she told
my mom and then she was like yeah he did
it to
you know flocka too or whatever and then
i got in trouble
i got in trouble so like you know when
you're that small you don't you don't
you don't know what the [ __ ] going on
you don't know why [ __ ] is happening you
don't know what you know
and if somebody else is touching on you
and you you know the one person who's
supposed to be protecting you
like talks [ __ ] to you and yells at you
because you didn't say [ __ ]
instead of actually protecting you it's
like it kind of puts a wall up for you
so you know like that's that's kind of
how it all started
uh then started drinking at nine started
smoking weed at nine
uh my mother had came uh she moved
and she left me and my brother with my
grandmother so
uh you know we kind of just did whatever
we want you know i'm like my grandma's
favorite so she never questioned
anything i did anywhere i went and you
know who i was around
and that's kind of where everything
started do your mom was it to drugs
um she yeah she won't admit it but she
was into drugs she's not afford like she
wasn't a full-on addict
you know she was like a functional
addict here and there you know but
she she learned how to stop her however
she did it but
then your dad my dad was a full-blown
addict uh
full-blown i used to get high with my
dad uh well my stepdad but i called my
dad
um but when we moved to long beach
that's when like kind of everything just
started like
started hanging around with different
people getting into trouble fights like
just
i didn't really care you know if i had a
mother who you know was more involved
with her dude than
than her kids and then you know my my
my stepdad had kids and he has a lot of
kids so it was like a bunch of us all
you know at one point it was all of us
in one household and it was just
it was just chaotic i used to come home
high every day my mother never knew my
stepdad never knew because i would just
go straight to the room and just
you know block everything out i was
always in trouble i was always grounded
if i entered the door when i was
grounded and my parents walk in
i'm grounded again for being at the door
you know it's just like little [ __ ] like
that it's like as a little girl it's
like
what the [ __ ] am i doing wrong like what
what is it like what what's going on you
know like
but it's like you know back in the days
you don't talk
like parents don't talk to their kids
like that you know there's no dcfs or
this like how they have all these rules
now so it's like everything just gets
swept on the carpet and you know you
just keep on moving you just
you know so i i left at 14
got with my first baby's dad got
pregnant at 15.
uh that was that was just like a whole
another life
uh right there just being pregnant is at
15 is i mean it's a scary ass thing you
know
i got kicked out of school for being
pregnant because they were scared that
like
i was going to influence the other girls
to be pregnant so i spent a little time
out like you know not going to school
then i found a school where i can go
while i'm pregnant and also have my kid
there so i started doing that
you know my baby's dad was into gangs so
by the time my son was like two months
he went to jail for 20 years so i raised
my son on my own for like
first year or two i was working i was
going to school i was you know doing my
internship for
rn like you know i was on my [ __ ] and
then
but i was i was still partying every
weekend still drinking every week and
always had my son
never neglected him never did nothing
you know he was always cheat up like i
never you know
i was i was a really mean mother you
know like
everything wasn't all pretty and [ __ ]
but uh that's when i met my
my second baby's dad and that just
that's where like everything just went
to [ __ ] i have
i have four kids now um
from the moment i had my first daughter
that's when i started using meth
and it just it was just an everyday
thing and everyday all day thing
house was always dirty you know the kids
were fed they went to school and all
that but
it was just it was a whole other site of
neglect for the kids you know
[ __ ] that i that i experienced as a
child that i never wanted to
you know bring to my kids and that's
exactly what i did and i did it 10 times
worse
so that went on for a few years
the whole dcfs got involved lost the
kids
uh got him back lost him again
just i mean i don't know it's just it's
been chaos
it's been chaos you know going in and
out of jail
uh using dope selling dope
doing all kinds of you know illegal
activities that i will not repeat but so
you joined the gang
eventually no i know i never joined the
gang i never joined i was always the
type to uh
i'm always against authority so like
even in a gang it's like you have rules
you have you know certain places you
can't go certain people you can't talk
to
and i'm just everywhere i don't care
i'll talk to whoever you know like
you know if i see that you're cool like
you know if i could if we could do a job
together and
like we'll do it most of the time i do
my jobs on my own because i don't like
uh nobody knowing what i'm doing or you
know there's always snitches around
so huh no prison time uh
i've never actually been to prison but
i've been to jail a whole lot of times
uh this last time it's like going on
three i just got out
like two and a half three years ago um i
did 11 months
uh for a whole gang of dope that
you know i got caught up with it wasn't
mine uh it was actually
uh a family members and and and a guy
that i was messing with throughout the
time
at that time um and i had my kids with
me
but it was like i had no record and you
know
my dude or whatever he was uh who i was
messing with at the time like he would
have
you know went to jail for a long time my
family member would have uh
did a lot of time and then got deported
so in order to kind of save them and
everything and not make it such a big
deal
i took the fall for everything and uh
yeah i went to jail with you know they
got me for uh
intent to distribute because i only had
the dope i didn't have
a scale no bags no money no none of that
so they didn't they couldn't get me for
sales
but they gave me two and a half and i
ended up doing 11 months
but it's just i i think with the whole
that whole thing that went down
uh you know that's when you know
detectives get involved and you know
they try to sit you down it's like a
real life
like how you see it in the movies when
they sit you on at the table in two
chairs and an empty ass room and
you know he's like sit down and he's
like we can make all this go away and i
was just like
uh no like i'm i'm good you know [ __ ]
you like
he's like you just gotta do three jobs i
was like i'm good look i i know what i
did i admitted it just given my time
let me you know and
so the consequences of that was like me
basically losing my kids
i wanted you to be an informant yeah and
i just i couldn't do it so i got bailed
out
and when i went to court i had that dude
that i was messing with at the time he
went with me
and uh even my attorney or the the
public defender he was like um
you know can i talk to you like on the
side or whatever so we kind of moved to
the side but like the dude was still
sitting there taking here and he's
like okay so you know you're helping the
detective and i was like no the [ __ ] i'm
not like
because it could be any little thing
they say and it's like anybody hears it
like that's it you're you know
you're burnt you're done you know and i
was like nah [ __ ] that take that off my
record i'm not helping no [ __ ]
detective none of that [ __ ] like just
give me my time
because he's like well i can't help you
you know i was like i don't care i'm not
asking you to help me just give me my
time
and and that's it you know i'm not i
didn't ask for your help
i just tell the judge whatever needs to
be said and that's it give my time and
let me you know i'll be out there for
you know a [ __ ] away
and he was like all right and i think
that's the first time i ever got scared
um as far as like dealing with the whole
gang you know environment
um because you know people don't play
when it comes to [ __ ] like that
and i'm definitely not knowing
performance so and i mean as far as the
way i
i grew up and the people i grew up
around you know that's just something
you don't do
um i know the game has been washed up a
little bit but
you know my like you know my values my
like
all the rules i go by are from back in
the days so it's like
it's just you know that's kind of why
i'm still doing the same [ __ ]
like now i'm tomorrow i'll be 33.
and i was in a program i literally snuck
out last night
to you know go see my dude and that went
all bad
um and then i'm back here at skid row
[ __ ] same [ __ ] back and forth back
and forth because
it's like you know you want to do good
but
you know all the damage all the chaos
you've caused in your past it's like
you know there's barriers there's foot
you know there's obstacles you got to go
through and it's not always easy for a
female
and um so yeah like i just you know
are you raising the kids um i raise them
for the first few years
my youngest one is probably the only one
that i didn't really raise
she was a year when they took her from
me um
and it was it was so stupid too because
i had been clean
uh i was clean and and you know the
social worker came they had me trying to
get a hold of me
they were they were living with their
dad at the time and i was just kind of
everywhere
and they're like you know we need you to
come in and test
and i have been clean for like at least
three four days and the day of the test
i went and got high and it was like you
know who the [ __ ] thinks of [ __ ] like
that like
you know you your whole case could have
been closed if you would have just
waited to go test and then go get high
or
not get high you know um but that's just
how [ __ ] attic minds think like
or we don't think we just you know we
just do you think there's some
self-destructive streak that just makes
you kind of sabotage yourself
yeah all the time uh we were talking
about this in a in
in rehab the other day like you know
just self-destruction self-sabotage fear
of
of not knowing if i can succeed or if i
can make [ __ ] happen like
yeah so it makes you just not want to do
it it makes me not want to try and it's
easier to just [ __ ] everything up and
you know because i know my kids are good
um
like well taken care of they're not in
they're not they're in the system but
they're not in the system you know
they've always been with family
so i think i use that like to just be
like [ __ ] it like
i can't give him nothing right now like
i can't give him a home i can't i can't
feed him i can't do [ __ ] so it's like
i just kind of go with that and i know i
shouldn't but
you know that goes along with just guilt
and and the [ __ ] i put them through the
[ __ ] they've seen
and and it's really no [ __ ] that kids
should never see you know
like sitting here taking a gang of pills
trying to kill myself and the kids are
looking
at me like what's going on mom and you
know running rushing me out the house to
the hospital and it's like
you know kids don't need to see [ __ ]
like that or just
it was just so much violence so much
violence my kids seen a lot of violence
and i'm talking about not just you know
going heads up i mean like destroying
the whole house
you know barricading yourself in the
house throwing knives stabbing
like the like everything had them living
in you know room to room
like it's just like [ __ ] that kids don't
need to see you know
um so
right now i just feel like uh i feel
like i'm living out my karma type
you know um who knows maybe
you know god has something different for
me later on but for right now
i mean i even lied to my parents you
know i was like i'm not going to leave
you know it's like it's the last time
i've never had a breakthrough with my
mother
uh and when i was when i was at the
rehab
a couple days ago like i finally text
her and in all honesty i only text her
because i knew she was going to bring me
money and cigarettes and stuff like that
so i was like
let me just hit her up real quick and so
i did but it was like a whole nother
experience because as soon as i hit her
up uh you know it was just a quick text
she was at work
and she was like uh you know asking if i
was okay why haven't i hit her up or
whatever and then
she was like when i get off of work i'ma
call you and i'm over here like well
don't call me because i'm not supposed
to have a phone in rehab but i do
so just text me and i'll call you so she
calls me and she's crying
like and you know for me for my mother
to cry
because of the [ __ ] i'm doing is
something
i've never i've never like experienced
we never had that bond you know so
she's like you know what you know you
are my daughter you think i don't love
you think i don't you don't think i
don't worry
and like that [ __ ] made me cry only
because we didn't you know we've never
had that so i'm just like damn like i
really am a [ __ ] up ass
like she pays for my phone like she's
been paying for my phone since i got out
of jail it's going on three years
i like i don't give her [ __ ] for the
phone and i got a brand new phone like
i don't pay the bill every month and she
just she just keeps paying she
you know she sure enough she was like
i'm gonna take your cigarettes i'm
taking money
i'm gonna take your food and i was like
i'm not gonna leave this time it's
different like you know
and here's the [ __ ] i am again back on
skid road and she's
you know she don't even know it yet um
but i mean i don't know it's just it's
being an actress is is [ __ ] up like we
don't ever think about the consequences
or the people we hurt
when we're in our addiction you know
you've been through rehab a lot uh yeah
it's like my
at least my ninth tenth time being in in
rehab i've completed only two times
uh the rest is just either i'm about to
complete it and i
[ __ ] up or i'm just like you know what
i'm out like and i you know
which that's mostly what it is it's like
i get there stay there a day or two and
it's like all right i'm gone
um this last time i i probably went back
like six times already
in the last month and that's only
because i'm tired of being
you know here on the streets and i think
this last run was probably the first
time i've ever actually been on skid
road
or skid row like like actually you know
in it
and it's just it's a crazy experience
but you know it's my mom always says if
i could just slap you out of it you know
you'll be good and i'm just like well
if you can slap the addiction out of us
then [ __ ] nobody would be addicts like
you know we wouldn't have this problem
but
you know here we are so um i mean i
don't know i saw him
didn't really go into much details but
do you think that the problem is the
addiction or do you think it's the
the low um i think it's more i think
it's more like
you deserve crap so you i think it's
more of the lifestyle
um because i mean i just had a
breakthrough too with with the whole
like guilt
and and feeling like you know i the fear
of of the unknown for the future
if i you know if i get my kids back will
i lose them again
um but i think it's more of like the
lifestyle because
i mean there's times where i have done
good you know i i was with
a guy we moved to tracy we had a five
bedroom house cars every like the kids
went to like the best white school and
you know
schools where you gotta like it's not an
option for you to donate to the school
it's and it's an obligation you know
and um i've had a good life you know
there's
here and there but there's times where i
i was i was good
and um it's still it's still the
lifestyle the lifestyle is like
you know i'm gonna i'm in an area where
i don't know nobody and um
i always feel like i got to defend
myself so you know if somebody comes at
me talking proper or saying some stuff
that i don't really understand
like i'll take it as like they're you
know attacking and it's not it's just
because like i'm so close-minded
sometimes that i don't
you know i don't try to understand the
next person um
and i'm just so quick to you know like
[ __ ] it like all right so
what's next you know like move on and
and and i'm i'm really good at leaving
you know like something don't go right
or if i [ __ ] it up enough
i'm gone you know and and i'll disappear
for like a couple days couple weeks
couple years
come back and start the process all over
again start doing good then you know
realize all right i'm doing good like
you know i could get high
real quick or or i could go make this
quick money or whatever and then
that's when you know it starts all over
and just start losing [ __ ] little by
little until i'm
back here and it's just kind of how it's
been for
the past 12 13 14 years
and you know i wish i could say like
this is done like i'm
you know like i'm you know but i don't
know because
i know i know inside i do want to feel
like like i do feel like this is over
now and i want to turn my life around
but then it's like
any little thing will happen like for
instance you know this morning like i'm
over here chilling with this dude or
whatever and because he's coming down
off of his [ __ ] we kind of get into it
and then now it's like
well [ __ ] it i'm not going back to the
program and i still have a chance to go
back without them knowing i left but
it's like this is look where i end up
you know end up here
[ __ ] getting high and it's just it's
crazy it's crazy this
you know this this addiction is is real
it's it's powerful it's what do you
think most people don't understand about
addiction
um are not addicts i think the
the biggest thing they they struggle
with is just not understanding
like not understanding what the drug
does to you
as far as your body your mind as far as
the whole craving you know
like releasing dope means all of that
they get into all of that details when
you're
in rehab but it's like when you're not
an addict
or even even for the addicts who like
are you know
functional addicts or like occasional
addicts you know
um even they don't understand like it's
just
it's kind of like having a uh like a
sugar craving or chocolate craving or
whatever or
a hobby like you know it's like if you
like biking it's like you don't know why
you do you just i mean well you know why
you do it but
whatever feeling that gives you that's
what makes you want to keep doing it you
know people that hike people that golf
people that
it's like it's it just makes you feel a
certain way in it and
and that is exactly what dope does it's
just it becomes your first priority
right and it's it's it's it's not even
like second nature it's like just
first nature type [ __ ] right and then
you got the drugs that make you uh
you know actually physically sick if you
don't keep using you know
the type where your body your whole body
could shut down luckily meth is not like
that it's just
you know you sleep for a couple days and
you wake up and you're good
you might you know you might feel a
little weak because you're overworking
your body but
there's no actual physical pain where
you need to like
you know be medicated or whatnot um so i
always feel like i don't have it that
bad
but i mean any drug that you do is bad
it doesn't matter how bad it makes you
feel when you're coming off of it or not
it's about where it takes you while
you're in your addiction you know
and um it's just people do crazy [ __ ]
like
would you be surprised like the [ __ ]
this whole past year the [ __ ] i've been
going through the [ __ ] i put up with
just because of dope like
all the fighting all the getting beat up
like it's just
it's it's crazy but you for whatever
reason we deal with it
we accept it we we live it we you know
we
give that same negative energy to the
next person and it's all because
you know we just want to be high do you
feel like it's a generational curse
um it's maybe not a maybe not a curse
uh it's more of like i mean i guess you
could see it as a curse
i see it as role models the role models
you have well yeah because uh
you know the the when we were growing up
uh
you know my stepdad he used a lot he i
mean he was high every day
but he always you know he always went to
work we never
were homeless we never were out of food
like we always had everything but he was
always high
and yeah he did the whole my mom had
people living behind the
you know the tv and you know there was
all kinds of guys everywhere and i know
that was in his mind but when you're
small you don't know that
so then when i started using uh
i was using my baby's dad i know for a
while he thought that
it was his fault why i started using but
i told him
you know after a while it's like you
can't make you can't force somebody to
get high you know
even if you know you did encourage it to
try it it was my choice after that to
keep on using
and and it ended up being a drug that i
loved you know
um so i used every day and yeah i got to
a point where i was using with my dad
um up until the day i got arrested you
know this last time
you know i was with my dad all the time
always going to work with him every you
know everything it got
it got to a point where
my dad was you know kind of having
problems with one of my brothers
and his wife decided to call the cops
and
you know kind of say everything and
she's like yeah well you know
she's over here like her and her dad
over here [ __ ] and i was like what
the [ __ ] like
[ __ ] i had my sisters calling me like
what the [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
and i was like what the [ __ ] are you
guys talking about my mom's calling me
talking [ __ ]
and i was just like what the what in
your right [ __ ] mind makes you think
that i would ever sleep with my dad like
i know he's not my real dad but he's my
dad to me i was a little ass girl when
you know when he came into our life so
to me that's my dad and it was
it was a big issue um because my mom and
him weren't living together at the time
she was living in arizona he was living
with my brother
he kind of had the back room it was like
all the way in the back and it's just
like
yeah i was always with my dad yeah i
could sleep in the same room as my dad
but he'll either be on the bed or on the
floor you know like it wasn't it was
never that type of [ __ ]
and it caused a lot of drama of course
it plants that seed in people's minds
you know like
okay well they're both not saying it but
who knows it could have happened they're
both getting high
you know people do [ __ ] when they're
high and
and it was just like you know that it
yeah that put a big big wall in between
me and
and a lot of my family members um and i
mean i ain't got nothing to lie about
i know in my heart that has never
happened um
it would never happen um but yeah when i
went to jail my dad got sick
uh he's he got you know he was dying he
was his heart gave up
um that's when he decided to change his
life around
um and i didn't know nothing about it
until i actually got out of jail
and you know he was on all these
medications he had lost so much weight
and i was just you know it was kind of
an eye-opener and i and
i was happy to see that my dad was clean
but
it's for whatever reason it just was it
wasn't enough for me you know it wasn't
my time yet
and you know i would say like uh
just because it's around you or just
because you grow up that way it doesn't
always mean that you need to
you know you need to follow those same
steps you know you
everybody still knows right from wrong
you know even if your whole household
does
dope or or or gang bangs or whatever
it's like
you get to a certain age where you you
know yourself do you want to you know do
you want to join this do you want to be
a part of it or do you want to live a
different life you know
so i never really blamed like my
addiction or anything that i do
on like like from growing up you know
because i mean i don't really care how
stupid you are you always know right
from wrong
um and of course i've always you know i
i like the adrenaline i like the rush
you know i i like taking risks i like
doing [ __ ] that i know i could get
caught up for
and and so that's why i just i just kind
of went with it
but then yeah i have a problem with
authority so i just kind of never did
the whole gang thing i used to hang
around with them and you know do certain
jobs but i never actually
you know became a gang member and mainly
because i was just
all over the place different cities you
know different hoods so it's like
uh i can't really i can't go to another
place like well i can't talk to you
because you know i'm from here
that's just to me i don't know how that
i don't know but so i never really
joined the game but yeah
i mean i've been around dope my whole
life you know dope alcohol as far as for
you know mexicans in my family you're
never really an alcoholic
because everybody drinks i think the
only person who's actually ever
considered an alcoholic in my family was
my grandpa
and that's because he died from it when
i was a little girl who also
which i lied to my mother about this to
um kind of had a breakthrough when uh
when i first got out of joe was
christmas and it was just me and like
three of my sisters and
you know i guess they were drunk and
they were feeling some type of way so
feeling started coming out and
and and you did this when i was small
you did this and and
you know my mom was like well i was you
know my whole fear was that you know
grandpa was going to do something to you
guys
and you know because he was a drunk like
he didn't know what he was doing and
and i looked at her and i didn't have
the heart to tell her like well
you know yeah it did happen but i mean
if you were so scared that he was going
to do something to us why did you put us
in that situation you know what i'm
saying
why did you have him there so that's
what i didn't understand about it and
that's why i didn't i didn't tell her
like yeah you know like
he did he tried like um but to me that
was my grandpa and
and even though i didn't let him do
anything
i still couldn't i still couldn't be mad
at him you know i still couldn't have
like i couldn't hold a grudge to get him
against him i couldn't i didn't have no
resentments
um i loved him he was grandpa you know
didn't matter what day it was he'll take
you to the store and he'll get his beer
and his scratchers and he'll let you
scratch one and that that was our day
with him you know
and it was the everyday thing um but
till this day my mother does not know
uh that he also tried and it was around
the same time
when you know their friend had did
you know what he had did to me um
and i don't i don't i don't know if
she'll ever see this uh but i don't
think i would ever have the heart to
tell her because
i know that that was one thing that that
she feared
that she you know she really broke down
and cried and told us like that was my
only fear with you guys
and i mean i kind of didn't want to like
throw it in her face type [ __ ] but
i mean i have daughters too and and i'm
very very overprotective with my
daughters like
nobody can come near them no friends
could come to the house
like my i have an older son he's about
to be 17.
uh he couldn't bring his friends to the
house because i had little girls you
know
and it's [ __ ] like that that you think
every mother would do
you know to make sure that their
daughters are protected and
and so that's what i did with my
daughters and she just i just feel like
that was one part that she failed to do
so i just kind of felt like well why are
you so like you know why are you crying
about it why are you making it seem like
it's a big ass deal when you put us in
that situation you know
it's like so yeah it's kind of just been
real iffy but um
but that's also one of the consequences
of what i what i
what i put my kids through my son is
about to be 17 and
he's right now in jail um when i went to
jail he kind of left the [ __ ]
uh foster system he you know started
running away started
pretty much doing everything that you
know he's seen me do you know
robbing stealing you know
doing [ __ ] you know hurting other people
you know it's just
and and when i got out of
jail his father actually got out a
couple months later
uh the one that had 20 years
um and we had we had children's court
and i remember
i was talking to my son's grandmother
and i was like you know is junior gonna
come by or whatever
like is he going to court and she's like
no so when i'm when i'm there i'm
talking to my attorney and i turned and
i
see i could have swore it was my son
standing right there
and i did like a little quick double
take and
i mean i thought it was my son and i
looked and it was you know it was baby
daddy and i was like oh [ __ ]
um and i hadn't seen him in 15 16 years
he was he was one of those uh obviously
my first love what i thought was love
first person i had ever been with
it was one of those like i never wanted
kids with different guys so i was
willing to put up with whatever
whatever our relationship was going to
turn out to be i was willing to
to go with it so that it would just be
us you know
and uh his i remember his trial went on
for like a year or two
and i was still living with his parents
uh
but it was every day like you're you're
doing this you're cheating on me
nobody's gonna love you nobody's gonna
watch because you have kids
like it was so much i was like crying
every day and then
once the year was up i was like you know
what i'm gone like i'm the only one
taking care of our son i would never ask
his parents for nothing
i never asked him for nothing they never
paid for nothing they they never like
i would get up every day go to school i
would walk to school take the bus i
never asked them for [ __ ] even though i
was living at their house
um but i paid for babysitting i paid for
everything like i didn't there was
nothing asked so when you know when that
year came up i was like what the [ __ ] am
i doing like why am i dealing with
[ __ ] and this is somebody i was like
willing to wait the whole 20 years for
like i was gonna be straight loyal like
it's just me and him [ __ ] everybody else
i don't give a [ __ ] about anybody else
like we'll figure out ways to make this
work and after that year i was like man
[ __ ] you
like i'm over here going to school going
to work doing all this
helping out your family for you to call
me
like he would call like at least 10
times a day i know you're [ __ ] this
person now you're [ __ ] like what the
[ __ ] like oh shut the [ __ ] up like and i
just
and i had never ever ever raised my
voice at him
i never yelled at him i never cussed at
him i never
nothing it was just like you know he'll
come home whenever he wanted to be like
make this i'll make it for him you know
would
[ __ ] [ __ ] whatever go to sleep the
next day he'll be gone and it'll be the
same thing all over again
and i never said nothing and there was
girls that would call the house like
yeah i just [ __ ] your man and da da
and he's over here saying
you know that that baby's not his and
all this [ __ ] you know and i never
said
nothing i never never questioned it
nothing until i got tired of it
and i remember one day he called and and
i was just like you know what [ __ ] you
[ __ ] everything like you're just you're
you're no good like
and that was probably the first time i
ever yelled at him or cussed at him or
anything and he just he didn't know who
i was anymore like
and that's just kind of how our
relationship has been since then
uh i never kept my son from him or his
family
they were more than welcome to come pick
him up see him or take him to go see him
i never
you know i never denied him that i never
spoke to my son about
his dad because i'm not the type to be
like
oh you know your dad says your dad's
that like no like
just you go see your dad you have your
own opinion you have your own
relationship with him you'll see
like when you get older you'll you know
you can make that determination or
whatever
and so when he got out you know he
i i gave up custody to him
uh because they wanted to you know form
a bond or whatever my son was for it so
i told him
he's older so it's not like we got to go
with what dcfs says or anything or
social workers or
courts it's basically what my son says
because if not he'll just up and leave
just like me just
kind of like how i taught him um so he's
like yeah i want to be with my dad
gave up my rights so he could go with
his dad
that worked out for about a month or two
ran away from dad
you know did all this [ __ ] and and now
he's in jail you know
and it's just it's just a cycle it's a
cycle that we continue to [ __ ]
you know with every generation it's like
when the [ __ ] does it stop
you know it's not the life that i wanted
my kids to have it's not the path i
wanted
my son to go down and it's just like
it's exactly what's happening you know
just trying to figure out
where i need to be you know if i'm if i
don't know if i'm gonna continue
to use or if you know i finally get it
together but that's just part of being
an addict you know
you think you hit rock bottom but then
you don't and you just keep going and
going and going
either until you die or you're
hospitalized or
you know just it's
just it so i gotta figure out where i'm
at right now all right well good luck
thank you thank you for coming in yeah
thanks for having me
you